I was saying that as far as we're
talking about Aesthetics and whatnot
um it's not hard I'm not trying to sound
egotistical I get male attention anybody
can get male or female attention
regardless regardless anybody five and
above men no shortage of male attention
men can't get female attention like
women can women women are born with it
men have to earn it earn it and after
and give yourself 10 years it won't be
easy yeah it kind of falls off for a
woman after 40 seconds
finish what you're saying but I'm not
I'm just gonna say like
what I struggle with is a man looking
beyond the physical a little bit in the
sense of understand the substance behind
it it's like a lot of the times because
you're quite unquote in a um an
attractive and I don't really like to
say his face will even saying it an
attractive or desirable woman or male
they look at you and think okay you
might have the package or you might have
certain things but they might not be
willing to actually look beyond that and
think actually there's substance there
you know is they can feel your energy
you said do you want sex at this time
sometimes I want sex by their substance
and they're not looking for substance in
it so you know what Lane you've been put
into if he's not willing to look behind
then he doesn't want to well and and the
thing is like you are attractive so you
can get that like the male attention but
the problem is when you have three kids
they put you in the for fun
it's not a disrespect thing you know
like it's actually not I want to want
women to understand when these things
are said it's not a disrespectfulness
it's basically what Paul's saying is
she's trying to give give you an insight
into the male mind she's trying to give
you an insight into the way in which
males think she wants you back yeah
men like they think of they put women
and the thing is women do it too they
put men in categories do you know what
I'm saying like men put women in
categories and it's like women need to
all we're saying is we're just exposing
the cat we're showing you the categories
now and the thing is is that a lot of
women will hear what has been said and
be like
and think they know better and it's like
but men will consistently and
continuously tell you and you will
continuously and consistently not listen
because don't attack the messenger and
they can't attack the message the truth
is the truth then it becomes about then
it becomes about you you know well
you're just saying that because it's you
and I was like listen listen the man who
you you the man who you look up to was
more Amanda me they think the same thing
I think they just ain't telling you that
because they're having too much fun well
and at least at least if at least if you
have the information you can move
accordingly yeah and remember most guys
having children
no you can't you can't take back having
children but if you're like you just
have to look at your options for the
next 10 years that's what I'm willing to
compromise but I'm not willing to
compromise a man that doesn't want to
look beyond the physical is what I'm
trying to say as well
tell you the truth because they're
trying to get into your knickers you
need to listen to the guys that aren't
trying to get into your knickers the
guys that aren't trying to get into your
knickers are going to tell you the truth
the guys that are going to talk they're
trying to get anything they will tell
you anything to get in there yeah do you
understand yeah but you did say that you
valued X as the biggest thing and that
was like what you were doing right now
during the time like like right
well maybe I was just been a bit too
hasty in it let's just be right no
you're being honest isn't it you'll be
honest let's like dive into that
right can I just try and explain a
little bit okay
is that
man being
um sure of himself being confident you
know having a certain level of
um family values and like everything is
is everything if that was true when we I
asked you the question would you would
you pick the finances
I know and that's who you know
no no I said I said no no no no no no no
no no we could we could we could we
could rewind the tape and
and we could go back and cut it
to where I said to where I said no no no
we're not in the business of changing
men these are the options and and she
and she said that she would pick the guy
with the job and the financial stability
she did say she did say she would cheat
on him so I don't know if that's better
um
which is which is good but I think you
might value the wrong things because the
bomb is gonna make a good step dad
I understand this I understand the
feminine urge to try and like twist it
into something that sounds somewhat
reasonable but I think really really you
know that that's what you actually want
because at the moment
so why did you say sex first and
foremost
um the the driving
um driving force in that situation in
that comment right in that question
however I also want somebody I could
enjoy life like everything I'm working
hard for right now in life I want
somebody I can ultimately enjoy it with
that includes great sex I know I know I
know exactly the guy men lead with once
you've been relaxed before yeah you've
got three children I know exactly
take her back she's sorry she didn't
mean what she said it's not too late
Checker oh my God okay I'm gonna I'm
gonna try again
we're gonna have to round up yeah
Adonis 1909 her feet are in the pit now
um French Biz lady in the red you keep
talking about substance but you are
judging but you can't be the one judging
said substance you don't judge your
value men do Wendell coven make the
ladies bring facts to their points 50
Super Chat Sarah dropping Bob
um 90 free-toe pay um Pearl next time
your guests say not all please make them
put five dollars in a jar they have to
stop neon Moses lady in the green are
you married he's interested how am I
married yes no you could be according to
this guy
okay Punisher um if you want a wife to
if you want to be a wife in a happy
marriage you only need one skill to make
the man you want feel like your support
means he can attain for your family the
things you both want for it 90 free Tope
and lady in green
men build up you you cute good can't
read I'll teach you women start from the
top you all move in
um whoa
um okay 90 free-toe pet oh and I read
those already earlier okay
um Manny F Pearl you should ask the
ladies if they if any of their male
friends would smash them and test them
with the smash text
um just human Pearl have ish signal your
intermission so you can read the Super
Chat French Biz lady in red it's not
that the man you go for lack masculinity
if you aren't in your feminine it's it's
that your starting point as a female is
too high Wendell coven well the ladies
in the pink and the red make changes
after listening to what men want or will
they stay the same Vincent docile fat
chicks deserve love just not from me
just human just human masculine men
operate with honor and discipline if we
he makes an agreement he will stand by
it monogamy included masculine men have
control over impulses it's feminine men
that will cheat no honor Mt Pearl would
you say that women leave a man for the
same reasons they were attracted to him
aggressive she turns she turns him
emotionally money no money
T-Mac 1979 one of the best conversations
ever on the show The Bros are bringing
it over analyzed men don't want to come
home to another boss energy after
dealing with boss energy in the office
kefir Hunter by 30 50 of your daily
dating pool is gone 90 of your eggs are
gone geriatric pregnancy starts at 35
and 36 then add in the Disney Princess
mentality no father households
overweight and overbees overweight obese
and argumentative me Mike shorty and the
green has been dassim and hinting at a
assortative mating if she opens a little
bit her mind a little bit to Pearl's
knowledge she stands a chance at finding
a decent man the other two are too far
gone Mr T1000 if Kevin Samuels had a
soundboard he'd be hitting all the
buttons right now I am Mack from 15 to
30 guys get rejected over and over again
by women life in later in life the
tables turn and women have no experience
of what rejection feels like and they
feel entitled reality does not care just
human women in pink a man you vetted
wants to discipline your child and you
don't agree with how why did you default
to an image of a man abusing them why
would you choose a guy to abused as your
children do you not trust men do you not
trust their judgment clockwise probably
please include links to the original
videos when you post clips of the
episodes you'll be roasting me sometimes
utmost give any man on this Earth two
million dollars a mansion a Lamborghini
and a blue check on Instagram I promise
none of the 32 year old none of them
would choose a 32 year old woman with
three kids wait to wake the hell up as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible